[Music]
the secret behind any great speech
it all it all begins with the speaker
you know having somebody who has that
worldview who who knows what they want
to say who knows what story they want to
tell that's critical I mean a speech
writer can come up with something on
their own but it really needs to be a
collaborative process with the person
who's speaking will you approach any
speech by asking yourself what story do
we want to tell we try to come up with a
headline for the speech first you know
whether it's one two or three sentences
because that's what you have to hang
everything on otherwise won't hold
together tonight I want to talk about
what kind of future we're going to have
and what kind of a nation we're going to
be one thing all great speeches have in
common is that they're bigger than the
place they say something bigger than the
moment you know something like Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address as I see said it
wasn't just to consecrate the ground
where soldiers gave their lives it was
to dedicate ourselves to making sure
that a nation conceived in Liberty can
endure so any great speech has to speak
to something bigger than that particular
moment you have to look beyond a
headline reading it the next day
absolutely beyond tweets we wouldn't
necessarily write speeches with an eye
towards what people will say about in
the 50 years but you're thinking about
the broader sweep of history and where
you fit today in the world of freedom
the proudest post is being a leader you
know other things that make a great
speech are authenticity and authenticity
is you know so did something more than
just the truth it's it's actually saying
what's true and I don't just mean facts
I mean things that people know the way
people speak in their everyday lives
not every great speech has to be up here
like Lincoln or Kennedy and people can
tell when you're trying too hard
a lot of times great speeches just
talking to people where they are but
courage always is something that's going
to carry me forth
[Music]
humor goes a long way in speeches but
it's also very hard the President Obama
would also say you know give me some
more jokes in here comedy is difficult
we're always very lucky that President
Obama had a great sense of comic timing
and he knew it but he was always good at
telling jokes he relished you know he'd
always dig it himself first and
self-deprecating way just to open it up
so that he could dig on somebody else I
am told that the last three speakers
here have been the Pope Her Majesty the
Queen and Nelson Mandela which is either
a very high bar or the beginning of a
very funny joke
you want to know where you aren't you're
talking to you if it's small as visiting
a high school and knowing do the mascot
is that handshake at the top of speech
goes a long way and then you have the
permission structure to take the
audience on a greater ride any aspiring
speech writer should just start writing
constantly whether it's journaling
whether it's you know preparing a speech
you wish you had the chance to write so
you have something to show somebody I'd
also say read widely you know that's
that's where if he comes from is
understanding other people's lives and
worldviews beyond your own I don't have
any classic training in speech writing I
started out as a pre-med student and
chemistry changed that course pretty
quickly but I would tell students you
know take a lot of history courses it
doesn't always have to be writing a
composition history economics philosophy
cuz you're gonna pull from all those
disciplines in any good political speech
with that I just have two more words to
say Obama
[Applause]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon